we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman if you're
trying to quit smoking or vaping check
out lucy which is a nicotine gum
developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save
20 percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman blinkist is
the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free and get
25
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman well we are back it is 2021
it is great to be back with you and
there is just so much to talk about that
i think
these last few weeks for donald trump as
we get to the end
these may be the craziest uh let's just
get right into it donald trump has now
been caught on
an audio recording of a phone call
pressuring the georgia republican
secretary of state brad raffensberger
to quote recalculate the election
results in georgia
in order to find about 11 000 votes
for donald trump and the the everything
about this
is absolutely nutty the washington post
obtained a recording of donald trump
urging georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger
to find a way to give donald trump the
victory in georgia
of course won by joe biden the current
president-elect
and donald trump on this phone call
we're going to listen to is speaking not
just to republican secretary of state
brad raffensberger but also to the
secretary of state's general counsel
uh donald trump's chief of staff mark
meadows also on the call
it's an hour-long call the full call is
available for you we're just going to
listen to a few clips
and this is really something else so
please understand
what this audio shows as if we didn't
know it
is that the president of the united
states is leading a campaign
a pressure campaign against democratic
elections
in order to remain in power despite the
results of that election
here is the first clip donald trump asks
raffensberger to please recalculate
we have won this election in georgia
based on all of this
and there's there's nothing wrong with
with saying that brad you know i mean
having
the having a correct if the people of
georgia are angry
and these numbers are going to be
repeated on monday night
along with others that we're going to
have by that time which are much more
substantial even
and the people of georgia are angry the
people of the country are angry
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know
that you've recalculated well mr
president the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong
now do you think it's possible that they
shredded
ballots in fulton county because that's
what the rumor is
and also that dominion took out machines
that dominion is really moving fast to
get rid of their
machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal that's ryan
germany no dominion has not
um moved any machinery out of fulton
county we're having no but no but
if they move have they have they moved
the inner parts of the machines
and replace them with other parts
no is yours ryan
i'm sure so just no to everything to
every one of donald trump's
notions they on the call saying
no no it's just that this isn't the case
that's not the case and trump
you know that that little are you sure
from trump that's like a mob boss
type of are you sure because it would
really be a shame if something were to
happen to this beautiful family of yours
after being told none of this is
happening
donald trump pulls out the big one and
starts speaking in more clear terms
says i just need you to find 11
780 votes and they are
removing machinery uh and they're moving
it as fast as they can
both of which are criminal fines and you
can't let it happen and you are letting
it happen or you know i mean
i'm notifying you that you're letting it
happen
so look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state when we say
high crimes and misdemeanors this is
exactly under that
umbrella that is the ask i need you to
find
11 780 votes so that i win
georgia and trump says it again later he
says come on guys
give me a break i only need 11 000 votes
here
so what so what are we going to do here
folks i only need 11 000 votes
fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a
break
this is criminal presidential
obstruction
in an election where trump himself is a
candidate it's not trump obstructing
some other election between two people
other than him
he's a candidate in this election it is
actually hard to find something a
president can do
that is worse than this in terms of its
impact on the democratic systems i know
you know there are other things that
have a death toll that we assign which
are
much more gruesome in nature for sure
and
killing people in in many ways is of
course
worse than making a phone call during
which you ask
someone to cheat for you from the
standpoint of what it does to the
pillars of democracy
this is almost as bad a thing as a
president can do the call is nuts and
trump
kind of switches between attacking and
criticizing raffensberger
and trying to sort of placate him and
flatter him it's very weird take a look
at this last clip
we won the election and it's not fair to
take it away from us like this and it's
going to be very costly
in many ways and
i think you have to say that you're
going to re-examine it and you can
re-examine it but but re-examine it with
people that
want to find answers not people that
don't want to find answers
for instance i'm hearing ryan and he's
probably
i'm sure a great lawyer and everything
but he's making statements about
those ballots that he doesn't know but
he's making him with such
he he did make him with surety but now i
think he's less sure because the answer
is they all went to biden
and that alone wins us the election
by a lot
you have people that submit information
and
we have our people that submit
information and then it comes before the
court
and the court then has to make a
determination we have to stand by our
numbers we believe our numbers are right
well under law you're not allowed to
give faulty election results
okay you're not allowed to do that and
that's what you've done this is a faulty
election result
this really is like nothing we have seen
before
it's not an exaggeration this is not
this is unlike anything we've seen in
the united states
um carl bernstein i believe saying that
this is
far worse than watergate dan rather
saying this is far worse than watergate
we've seen this stuff in other countries
no doubt
but we've not seen it like this in the
united states an ethical moral person
would say
i think maybe the count is wrong count
the votes
and give us the results trump says come
on guys
give me a break i need 11 000 votes the
difference
could not be more stark now trumpists
are split
of two minds on this right now there are
some trumpets who are playing coy
and they're saying trump didn't do
anything wrong trump said calculate the
correct results which we won with i
believe if you listen to the call
it's very hard to make that case trump
is very clearly saying something
different he's saying
regardless of the real results come on
guys give me a break
i need 11 000 votes other trumpists who
can't make that
dumb argument i just mentioned are just
pretending this isn't going on
if you look at some pro-trump enclaves
on the internet
they've been immediately deleting all
references to this story
removing all links to this story as
quickly as they're being posted
they're being deleted they're just
suppressing the story altogether
so is anybody surprised by this the guy
who said to ukraine and dig up dirt on
biden for me
no we can't be surprised by this now a
quick word on brad raffensberger
there's been some praise of brad
raffensberger floating around for
holding firm here and you know he did he
didn't bow
to trump's pressure and it takes some
strength when the president who happens
to be from your own party
is telling you what to do it takes some
strength to say no but remember that
this election didn't come down to just
georgia
when this phone call took place it was
clear that
even if brad raffensberger could somehow
steal georgia for trump
trump still doesn't win the election so
i
am wondering i don't know i'm wondering
would raffensberger and brian kemp from
georgia would they have held this
firm if flipping georgia would have
given trump the presidency i don't know
the answer to that i'm just asking
trump's participation certainly
justifies impeachment
and removal we have 16 days left in this
presidency
trump will be gone before impeachment
could happen you can impeach a president
after they've left
office it's warranted i doubt it will
happen
but completely impeachable behavior
there is a reason
that companies often escort former
employees out of the building right away
with presidents it's never been
necessary before
it's different with trump and that's
sort of the final thought on this
okay so we're back we have a huge week
this week this is
um tonight donald trump is going to hold
what will likely be his last political
rally as president in georgia
in support of incumbent republican
senators kelly lefler
and david perdue even though he's been
insisting that the georgia senate races
are rigged
he's still saying go and vote for kelly
and david
um we're going to cover that rally live
tonight
tomorrow are the two runoffs in georgia
tomorrow night we will cover
results live as they come in and then
wednesday january 6th
vice president mike pence is going to
preside over a formal counting of the
electoral vote
in front of a joint session of the house
and the senate and we have learned that
some republicans
are planning to try to steal the
election from joe biden who remember won
by
quite a bit this is the biggest attack
that we've seen
on the fundamentals of democracy in the
united states in a very long time
the term sedition is being used and i'm
here to tell you
that yes it is disgusting and no
it will not work so let's go through it
so that you understand why
these are delusional ideas that are
being
put forward by republicans
that on january 6th mike pence can
choose
instead of counting the actual electoral
votes for example
from pennsylvania biden one pennsylvania
democratic electors voted for joe biden
beautiful there are republicans claiming
mike pence can say
no i'm not going to accept those
electoral votes i'm going to accept
these
alternate republican electoral votes
from pennsylvania
he can't do that he mike pence cannot do
that that's not going to happen
that's a fantasy mike pence doesn't have
that power
mike pence's role in this is strictly
ceremonial
but what we are going to see are
objections
from the floor from both some house
republicans
and some senate republicans to the
counting of the electoral votes that
have been legally cast by electors
right now it's expected that there are
going to be 11 republican senators who
will claim
i object because of irregularities
and they will ask for an emergency
10-day audit to investigate now remember
they've been investigating two months
not a single court has found any of
their arguments meritorious
now the really scary part is that
because of the fomenting of baseless
anger by trump and others
there are expected to be multiple
rallies and gatherings of trumpists in
dc on wednesday
and there are fears of violence a
variety of groups are expected to be
there
there are threats of violence calls for
an armed encampment which sounds a lot
like that chaz and chop thing
that trumpists were denouncing over the
summer when it was over the george floyd
protests
but chas and chop only wanted to govern
themselves
these lunatics want to govern the entire
country by imposing
an unelected president on the united
states we've come to expect that
hypocrisy i won't dwell on that today
and they're even calling there are even
some republicans calling for violence
cuckoo congressman louie gohmert for
example
said in effect the court ruling would be
you gotta go
to the streets and be as violent as
antifa and black lives matter that's
louis gomer former judge
saying that attorney lynn wood who's a
pro-trump lawyer that's been at the
center of a lot of this nonsense says
mike pence should be executed for
treason so many
allusions and incitements to violence
going on and we'll see what happens on
that front on wednesday but the bottom
line
what happens voting wise on wednesday so
here's how it will go
some republicans will object to the
counting of the votes
it will trigger a couple of hours of
debate in each chamber
senate and house and then there will be
a vote about whether to uphold the
objections
neither the house nor senate will vote
to uphold the objections
and joe biden's election will be
certified that's what's going to happen
so all of this weeks of planning and
plotting and threatening this will lead
to a delay of a few hours on wednesday
and we will cover all of it live
for you they are attacking our basic
democratic systems
and they should be held accountable uh
it's unclear if these republicans are
going to be held accountable
but this is really the last thing we
need in the middle of a pandemic that
has dramatically been mishandled
where we have an urgent need to put
someone else in charge of managing the
pandemic
joe biden already has a team already has
a task force they've been meeting
they've been working
and there couldn't be this there would
it would never be acceptable to attack
democracy in this way
but this is an acutely bad time to do it
so let me know
on twitter what you expect to see happen
on wednesday you can find me on twitter
at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.compacman to build your
own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right new year new expectations
new membership code use the code
better21 why
come on guys because we want a better
2021 than 2020.
use the coupon code better21 all one
word all lowercase
numbers can't be lowercase but the
letters can better 21
to get a major discount off of the cost
of a membership at joinpackman.com
okay so even though donald trump has
been completely missing from
being the president for what is now
several months
he did post another one of these bizarre
videos on new year's eve and this is a
particularly deranged video i showed it
to some mental health professionals and
said
if this person were a patient and came
into the office making claims like these
what would you think
and everybody i showed it to in some
version or another said
i would question whether the patient is
losing connection to reality
we'd be thinking about whether
medication is appropriate now that's not
a diagnosis of trump it's a hypothetical
about
if trump was on your couch rather than
on your tv making these claims what
would you think so let's get right into
it a very odd five-minute speech posted
to trump's twitter
on new year's eve trump not slurring in
this particular speech his voice does
sound
strained let's get right into it in the
face of great challenges this year
americans showed incredible grit
strength tenacity and resolve
and together we achieved truly historic
victories like
nobody ever thought possible to defeat
the china virus we launched the largest
mobilization since world war
ii we transformed our factories to build
tens of thousands of ventilators and
millions and millions
of masks virtually overnight nobody
thought it could be done
we ignored the experts who demanded open
borders
and we shut down travel from china and
europe to protect our citizens
and we built the wall so this is trump's
completely delusional
revisionist history on covid we've been
one of the biggest global failures on
kovid
we failed on testing we are actively
failing on vaccination which we'll get
to tomorrow
but this isn't new information we have
the seventh highest per capita cases in
the world
we have the 12th highest per capita
death rate in the world
excluding a couple tiny territories like
san marino and andorra if we include
them were 14th highest
i won't bore you with more of that
you're likely as sick of hearing about
those numbers
as i am and then just last thing trump
casually says we built the wall
no wall was built the promise was a wall
across the entire border by january 20th
there's two weeks left there's no wall
let's keep going
we pioneered groundbreaking new
therapies and treatments and we saved
millions of american lives
over and over again we were told it
would be impossible to deliver a vaccine
by the end of the year
all of the experts said absolutely
unthinkable
trump is exaggerating it can't happen
and we did it
long before the end of the year they
said it would take a medical miracle
and that's exactly what it is years from
now they'll be talking about it they'll
be talking about this great great thing
that we did
with the vaccines a truly unprecedented
amazing medical miracle normally
developing
a vaccine takes up to 10 years thanks to
operation warp speed
we developed a vaccine in just nine
months
now the lies there are a bit more
nuanced
no one said this is a straw man
no one said you can't do a vaccine by
the end of the year and in fact you can
go back to my shows
in late april and early may and i showed
you
uh sober projections one was i believe
from goldman sachs which think what you
want about
them when it comes to these these uh um
timelines they've been pretty good
um and they said we we expect an
emergency use vaccine
sometime in november and healthcare
vaccinations could start at the end of
november or early december
that ended up being the case so it's not
nobody was saying we'd have a vaccine
this year
but remember that trump promised us a
hundred million doses by the end of
2020.
that failed he then definitely promised
us 20 million vaccinated by the end of
2020
we are only now getting to the first
four and a half five million doses
first dose given remember you need two
doses so
operation warp speed has fallen about 90
short of what was promised and that's
the bottom line fact
and then here trump really gets even
more delusional
we've already begun a nationwide
vaccination program
and we're sending the vaccine all over
the world
the world will benefit will benefit and
everybody's calling
to thank me we know of no calls
from world leaders thanking trump zero
we know of zero calls
but that's not really the big part to
talk about trump
says we're sending the vaccine all over
the world
that's about five layers of lies first
many of the vaccines have nothing to do
with operation warp speed
it's pharmaceutical companies that are
sending the vaccine
all over the world number two trump
turned down a hundred million doses of
the pfizer vaccine in late july
so the hundred million doses were then
sold by pfizer to other countries
we're not sending them we turned them
down so pfizer
sold them to somebody else we could have
had them trump said no
and now pfizer has figured out that
other countries want them and they're
sending them elsewhere
so just wrong on four or five different
levels
let's keep going trump then singing his
praises and grading himself
we will end the pandemic once and for
all this is one of the most
extraordinary scientific
industrial and medical feats in history
everybody has it as that
that's what they're marketed down as and
we can never let
people forget where it came from and how
it came
trump continues to be obsessed with his
marks as he calls them
says that the world has marked this down
as a major
success of course we have the pfizer
biontech vaccine
thanks to turkish immigrants in germany
the moderna vaccine
overseen by israeli-born chief medical
officer tal
zaks and french businessman ceo
stefan bonsell who's the ceo of moderna
and we have the oxford vaccine developed
in oxford
england starting to be approved what is
trump talking about
skipping ahead a little bit here um
trump touts his great economy
and then he goes into some real whoppers
about the gdp which we've been warning
you about for a while
our economy is growing at the most rapid
rate ever recorded
33.4 percent last quarter and much
faster than the nations of europe
nobody can compete with us this one is
just sad
we had rapid gdp growth in the third
quarter
after record gdp loss in the second
quarter
if you have ten apples and i take away
seven and then give you six back and
brag about how no one's ever given you
more apples than me
i'm kind of an idiot right nobody would
fall for that but people are falling for
the equivalent story that donald trump
is telling
and of course it's similar with europe
europe is seeing
slower gdp growth because they had less
gdp decline to begin with understand it
so it's a total farce and donald trump
rapidly approaching
uh his last and final public appearances
tonight in georgia in support
of the two republican candidate
candidates there i'll be covering it
live
i hope you'll join me on youtube twitch
and or facebook you can stream it on all
three at once if you want
uh starting about 8 30 p.m eastern time
tonight
this is really something else as as
we've been covering
joe biden has been doing a lot as
president-elect
donald trump as president hasn't been
doing a damn thing for months now
many of his allies have abandoned him
west palm beach doesn't seem to want him
down there new york city certainly
doesn't want him or his kids
it's just sort of a sad danumand for
donald trump
but trump has found some unwavering
support
in some elements of right-wing media
including oan newsmax
and still in some places on fox news the
the more sycophantic ones anyway
so later we're going to do a deep dive
into a particular fox news interview
that went comically haywire
but i want to give you a sampling of the
clips that donald trump has been
retweeting and amplifying
and the takeaway here for me is that the
next four years are going to be insane
that's that's my takeaway we'll see if
you come away with the same
notion fox news was nuts during barack
obama's presidency
but fox news competing with oan and
newsmax for the same audience is likely
to lead
to a sort of one-upmanship contest for
who can come up
with the most wacky anti-biden
conspiracy theories and false reports
so let's dive right in in the first clip
retweeted by donald trump there was a
panel on the show the five
about trump being admired in 2020 and
one of the five people figures out a way
to delusionally brown-nose donald trump
trump loved it and retweeted it take a
look
we'll see i think president trump stands
at the top because he has been
an incredible president he has though
marie he is someone who led
one of the strongest economies we saw
pre-kovet this is a man who has gotten
more middle east peace deals done
uh in just one term alone he's gotten
more than half of the
all the peace deals we have seen uh in
our nation's history done
done in one term this is someone who got
mexico to step up to the plate on things
like illegal
immigration this is someone who's
brought a business approach to
washington dc therefore see
solving problems when people like joe
biden who have been there forever
created the mess that president trump
went to go fix and i also think it's
remarkable
because you have a media who has
vilified him
demonized him lied about him and yet he
still sits
atop the throne and marie i love you but
this must be a hard segment to leave
so just to pick one thing because
there's so much nonsense here
she said half of all peace deals in the
nation's history
were done by donald trump during his
first term okay
that didn't ring true to me so i decided
i would fact check it
now some of these so-called deals trump
got done
were not even really peace deals and
i'll explain that in a moment
but if you go back to the treaty of
tripoli in 1805
there are 11 of what we would call
overtly
peace deals and then there are way more
that aren't called peace deals but
effectively are peace deals to some
degree
she says trump did more peace deals in
one term than were previously done in
all of american history
that is very much false but the real
issue is that the deals trump did are
really mirages
trump did a deal with the uae and israel
those countries had already agreed to
engage independent of trump and they
weren't in what we would call a conflict
to begin with
bahrain and israel same thing and then
of course trump's promise on
israeli-palestinian peace with jared
kushner was going to figure out for us
silence no progress at all another clip
these are clips retweeted by trump
sucking up to him this is from oan
a totally made up story fabricated out
of thin air
about military ballot tampering trump
loves it he retweeted it
well new investigations reveal military
ballots were
major targets of democrat voter fraud in
november
reports on thursday note thousands of
military ballots were potentially
tampered with at polling stations during
the general election this after several
witnesses came forward during a hearing
in georgia wednesday
with both photo and video evidence
of rampant fraud republican poll
watchers also claimed they got locked
out of the counting stations when it
came to look time to look over military
ballots which typically
lean red so that's absolutely nuts not a
single court has found
any merit to any of the claims you just
heard trump doesn't care
he loves it he retweets it next clip
also from oan
which presents a battle for the white
house battle
the election's over biden won trump lost
doesn't matter trump loves it this one
is made even funnier because the anchor
is struggling to deliver the scripted
agit trash like
she's she's struggling to even read this
nonsense off of the prompter
the battle continues for the white house
as president trump and his legal team
continue to reveal and
investigate the irregularities of the
2020 election
president trump has several avenues to
secure his second term
primarily the state legislatures have
the constitutional authority and
responsibility
to select the correct electors for their
respective states
seven states had both sets of electors
vote on december 14th
pennsylvania georgia michigan wisconsin
arizona nevada and new mexico
all had republican electors cast their
votes as well as the democrat electors
currently all seven of the state
secretaries of state have sent the
democrat electors to be counted
the state legislatures have the
constitutional responsibility
to ensure that the electors sent from
their state are correct
so that's a complete fantasy none of
that is going on
and then one more here may be the
nuttiest one an oan reporter
named pearson sharp stands in front of a
blackboard reminiscent of glenn beck's
old conspiracy show
a bunch of stuff written in chalk
outlining a completely
farcical understanding of how elections
work
this is a five minute clip i'm not going
to torture you like that
i'll just play 40 seconds for you to
give you a sense of it
the so-called election results on
november 3rd
are puzzling to a lot of people at least
75 million but probably
a lot more that's because up until that
point
all signs were that president trump was
set to win a historic
victory over joe biden and many still
believe that's exactly what happened
even if the alleged vote counts tell a
different story
despite what the mainstream media has
declared president trump
was projected to win because he had
ushered in
an unprecedented era of prosperity for
americans
from all walks of life at the start of
2020 before
the chinese pandemic and democratic
governors devastated
our nation american optimism about the
economy was at an all-time high
that guy has never seen a point he will
actually make
just droning on and on with
circumstantial
uh conjecture but his point is
trump won and trump liked it so trump
retweeted that video
these are the things where if you even
see a reputable reporter retweet this
you say
wow that's a concern the president of
the united states
is retweeting this stuff we'll have more
coverage of this
on our instagram page make sure you're
following us there
at david pakman show and follow me on
instagram for pictures from my vacation
warning they are very boring uh i'm
david
pakman on instagram the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online
from countless people who have used lucy
to quit smoking and vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
20 off when you use the coupon code
pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
welcome back to the david pakman show
this is an interesting story that did
not get a lot of attention since it came
out right around new year's day but i do
think it's worth
covering joe biden is going to have a
completely new secret service team in
his immediate presidential protection
team
and you might be saying well what's the
big deal uh new president new protection
team right well the big deal is that
um some reassignments are common when
there's a presidential transition
some agents move into being the people
right around the president
some move out of it joe biden is going
to be getting an entirely new team
though
because there are concerns about having
donald trump's sycophants
around joe biden secret service
is often considered a political simply
simply there to provide
security there are reportedly trump
sycophants that are now part of the
presidential protection team
individuals who for example were
discouraging each other from wearing
masks to be politically in line with
trump on kovid
even though officially the federal
government was saying all of our
employees are going to be wearing masks
the secret service allowed former
security detail leader anthony ornato
to temporarily leave his role and serve
as white house deputy chief of staff
very unusual very unorthodox decision
and that same guy ornato is the one who
coordinated
that insane stunt uh where trump held a
bible
in front of a dc church after the
clearing of peaceful protesters from the
area
he planned some campaign rallies and the
like so bottom line
they are going to be replacing the
entire presidential protection team and
to be frank i think this makes sense
it's terrible that this is necessary it
appears to be necessary secret service
agents are around the president during
extremely
sensitive events and meetings and the
idea that
some trump anti-massacres or loyalists
of any kind would be around
biden is horrifying and the plan is to
bring back
some senior agents that knew joe biden
from his days
as vice president and combined them with
some newer agents i actually never
thought that much
about the politics of secret service
agents
but then this guy dan bongino came along
and bongino was a secret service agent
who worked on protective duty
for george w bush and then he stayed on
with barack obama
and then we found out bongino is a
completely out of his mind right wing
nut
that would actually scare me as someone
protecting a president particularly a
democratic president
he's now part owner of the right wing
social media network parlor
he said that during trump's presidency
his life has become about
owning the libs that's a quote he
supported the spygate conspiracy theory
from donald trump and on and on
and on and my suspicion is that this is
actually going to be a bigger problem
than merely the secret service obviously
secret services of
particular importance because we're
talking about keeping the president safe
but my suspicion is that there have been
trump loyalists installed
at medium to lower levels in many
agencies
and often when you have a presidential
administration that changes
the leadership at many of those federal
government agencies also changes you
know
the directors and deputies to those
directors may maybe a little bit lower
than that
in order for everybody to sort of be in
line with the with the incoming
president but
because of how trump and his cronies
operate i would
guess that there are tons of loyalists
and cronies
below the level that a white house would
be involved in hiring for
and that is a a real concern and we'll
have to see
how that manifests during the first year
or two of joe biden's presidency you may
well have as a result of donald trump's
incredibly cronyistic handling of every
aspect of government
entire departments filled at the low to
mid level
with trump sycophants and loyalists so
my
guess would be that over the first 18 to
24 months of joe biden's presidency
we'll be hearing about these rogue acts
of defiance from low-level folks like as
an exam i'm not
predicting exactly this but as an
example uh
biden directs nasa to once again start
studying climate change
and some lower level folks refuse to put
the information back up on the website
maybe it's a bad example because nasa
actually does seem to be um
uh focused on doing good science but
that type of thing and it'll have to be
rooted out it'll sort of be equivalent
to
when the supreme court uh legalized gay
marriage nationally
you had that deranged wacky kentucky
county clerk kim davis
who just resisted uh issuing marriage
licenses in her county
obviously it failed she was just
replaced but she was temporarily held up
as a martyr
by some on the right it's going to be a
very interesting couple of years
so this is a really interesting story
and i know many of you have been
emailing me saying david you have to
cover this
i don't know how many of you expect me
to cover it in this way though so let's
dig right into it
fox news um i guess uh we'd call him
reporter
uh correspondent peter ducey the son of
steve ducey
also a fox uh host tried to embarrass
georgia democratic senate challenger
john ossoff on
air and it backfired horribly with
john ossoff delivering a perfectly timed
mic drop
but very important what john ossoff said
happens to be untrue
and we should also care about that so
i'm telling you
the truth here what assaf said was
rhetorically brilliant
but it was not factually accurate so
let's get to it georgia democratic
senate candidate rafael warnock
has had old assault allegations against
him reinvigorated
and they relate to his family life
which he's already discussed fox host
peter ducey brings these allegations up
not to warnock but to john ossoff
and ossoff executes a perfectly timed
brilliantly calculated and calibrated
rebuttal it is a textbook example of
rhetorical skill
when dealing with hostile media let's
take a look a quick one while we've got
yet
any any concern that the allegations of
wrongdoing
against reverend warnock could possibly
be a drag
on the democratic ticket next week none
whatsoever
reverend warnock addressed this issue a
year ago and here's the bottom line
kelly lefler
has been campaigning with a klansman
kelly lefler has been campaigning with a
klansman
and so she is stooping to these vicious
personal attacks
to distract from the fact that she's
been campaigning with a former member of
the ku klux klan
i mean we deserve better than that here
in georgia and i want to encourage
everybody to make a plan to vote on
tuesday thank you so much
thank you mr assaf very much all right
rhetorically
that is brilliant the pauses the
repetition
the redirection i mean it is really
perfect
john office is brilliant at this it also
happens not to be accurate
and that has not received the coverage
it should probably get and i'd be doing
everybody in my audience a disservice if
i didn't point this out
rhetorical skills do not necessarily
equate
to factually based dialogue right wing
host ben shapiro is a great example of
this he will
quickly rebut any argument you throw at
him and he will
sound confident doing it but the
arguments are often bogus
ossoff said that georgia republican
senate candidate kelly leffler
has been campaigning with a klansman
that is really not true in spirit you
might be able to find some way
where you can say the letter of it
approximates accuracy
it is true kelly leffler was pictured
alongside a former
member of the kkk named chester doles
chester doles was sentenced to prison in
the 90s for assaulting a black man
he was a member of the kkk but to say
that lefleur was campaigning with a
klansman
it's really not correct the leftler
campaign immediately said she has no
idea who this guy is she took a bunch of
pictures
with everybody who wanted one at that
event she condemns everything the kkk
stands for they would have kicked the
guy out if they had known who he was
so it's possible leffler has a soft spot
for white supremacists
independent of this event but when assaf
says leffler campaigned with a klansman
we're stooping to the sort of character
assassination stuff that they do
because there is no evidence cnn agrees
other fact checkers agree to say kelly
leffler campaigned with a klansman
suggests that the klansmen was part of
the campaign that she
welcomed the endorsement of a klansman
the clan's been introduced her
uh that is there's no evidence that
that's what took place here so
we must hold ourselves to the same
standard we we have to do it so
john ossoff is brilliant at this stuff
when he has the facts on his side
and he's brilliant at it when he doesn't
have the facts on his side that's what
makes it
all the more important for us to fact
check this stuff and know what's what i
enjoyed the clip i admit i did
it's not accurate lefler is disgusting
she appears to have profited
uh from kovid via her stock trades
and she's a total robot automaton she
can't put together a sensible critique
of her opponent rafael warnock without
repeating the same four lines over and
over about how he's a radical socialist
whatever
but i can't say i have evidence that
kelly lefler campaigned with a klansman
in the spirit in which john ossoff is
saying it here
great clip not factually accurate let me
know what you think
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
we are seeing a broken man falling apart
more and more acutely every single day
donald trump's presidency is now
in its death throws and donald trump
himself has been increasingly unhinged
retweeting
garbage right-wing media clips to his
twitter
while being missing in action as
president of the united states for
months now
and over the weekend he unleashed a
tweet storm
so unhinged so outrageous that it's hard
to imagine
what he's going to do when the day
finally comes
that he is no longer president of the
united states uh this is really bad for
the country truly bad
and it's not just humiliating for trump
it's humiliating for the country
globally they are crying for us yes
because of the coveted mishandling and
the unnecessary death and suffering
they are scared for us yes because we
have such anti-democratic forces coming
out of the woodwork
in the republican party but they're also
laughing at us
because we have a president technically
anyway for a few more days
who can't stop tweeting trash after
trash
that almost no world leader would ever
be caught
dead tweeting trump again ranting
about so-called dead voters who don't
exist
tweeting why haven't they done signature
verification in fulton county georgia
why haven't they deducted all of the
dead people who voted
illegals who voted non-georgia residents
who voted
and tens of thousands of others who
voted illegally from the final vote
tally these are all lies
just a small portion of these votes give
us
a big and conclusive win in georgia have
they illegally destroyed
ballots in fulton county after many
weeks we don't
yet even have a judge to hear this
large-scale voter fraud case
the only judge seems to be stacy's
sister
referring to stacey abrams trump
insisting he won in a landslide saying
about a ted cruz tweet that this is
quote an attempt to steal
a landslide win can't let it happen
trump
attacking georgia republican officials
who are now the enemy because they won't
overtly steal the election remember for
all the praise of brad raffensberger and
these other georgia republicans who are
unwilling to do what trump wants
they were very willing to try to steal
the election via voter suppression
in fact georgia was sort of one of one
of the
the central places uh of purging voter
rolls and and shutting down polling
places like
georgia is the georgia republicans are
very willing to do some terrible stuff
they just weren't willing to do it this
way after the fact and trump is now
attacking them saying quote republicans
in georgia must be careful of the
political corruption
in fulton county which is rampant the
governor brian kemp and his puppet
lieutenant governor jeff duncan
have done less than nothing they are a
disgrace
to the great people of georgia and
donald trump just continuing to tweet
lies about georgia saying quote georgia
election
data just revealed shows that over 17
000 votes illegally flipped
from trump to biden this alone
there are many other irregularities is
enough to easily swing georgia to trump
quoting oan none of that is true there's
no evidence for any of that
no court has found any of these
arguments meritorious
or or with evidence trump then
interrupting the election tweets
to attack dr anthony fauci saying quote
somehow dr fauci is revered by the lame
stream media as such a great
professional
having done they say such an incredible
job
yet he works for me and the trump
administration and i am in no way given
any credit for my work
gee could this just be more fake news of
course trump
the theme is trump continuing to be
triggered by dr fauci being more
respected and trusted than trump
and when trump says fouchy works for me
i should get the credit well
you've been advocating for the opposite
of fouchy in many cases and attacking
him publicly for months now that's why
you're not getting the accolades
for for being the person who allows uh
fouchy to remain in your employ
and then trump continuing to spread more
lies about the virus which have deadly
consequences saying quote
the number of cases and deaths of the
china virus is far
exaggerated in the united states because
of the cdc's ridiculous method of
determination compared to other
countries
many of whom report purposely very
inaccurately and
low when in doubt call it covid fake
news now that one is not only untrue
if anything the number is understated
there's a new
cdc report that says okay we have the
official number which is around 350 000
dead from covid
already a tragedy um but we suspect
that the real number is more like half a
million for reasons we've already
discussed so
when trump says the real death toll is
lower he implies
it's less dangerous than it is which
encourages people to disregard
guidelines which save lives and then
donald trump retweeting a tweet from
lawyer sydney powell
who he supposedly doesn't have anything
to do with saying quote
this election was stolen from the voters
in a massive
fraud that you and others are now
complicit in
american elections are supposed to be
completely auditable
and transparent we the people demand the
truth
and the prosecutions of all who
committed voter fraud
and then trump lastly tweeting that he
will
be there at a historic day on wednesday
a march to stop the steal and
not to certify the 2020 election
i won't keep going this is just a
sampling
this is not a well person but he will be
gone soon the more important
issue is that this is really bad for the
country
and its negative effects are going to
persist beyond january
20th and we're going to have
significantly more coverage about that
coming up
later this week but also in later months
i have something for you today
which you might say is almost sad in a
way
this might be the saddest most pathetic
most embarrassing interview that fox
news host david
asman has ever done and i've been
watching david asman
on and off for decades at this point the
interview i'm going to play for you has
the feel and the vibe
of the north korean state media
broadcasts from how biased and
sycophantic it is
to the dear leader which in david
asman's case
is donald trump fox decided to interview
georgia republican secretary of state
brad raffensberger
who is a vile voter suppressing
pro-trump republican
who has become an enemy of trump because
he has said listen i
i can't just steal the election for you
and that was even too far
for brian kemp and brad raffensberger so
david asman
brings on brad raffensberger and frames
up a question for him that seems like a
north korean state media question
framing up a question about how it
really doesn't seem like biden even
could have won
because biden was in the basement and
operation warp speed was so great
this is a reporter from the supposed
news side of fox news listen to the
frame up on this question
folks outside of georgia and outside of
other the highly contested states
saying look at these numbers joe biden
got
12 million more votes than barack obama
on barack obama's best election i mean
how is that possible he spent the whole
the whole campaign bunkered down in his
basement uh
not saying much at all uh the president
has had enormous successes with the
economy with operation warp speed etc
how could he have done 12 million more
votes
than barack obama that's that's really
the overall
writing question in most people's minds
again the people who are out of the
weeds unlike yourself you can understand
those questions right
i do just imagine that
asmin claims you know most people people
who aren't in the weeds most people are
thinking
i don't know i mean biden was in the
basement trump won with operation warp
speed and he won with the economy and
biden gets 12 million more votes than
obama must be fraud
that's the average person that asman is
pretending exists now
those people do exist there's no doubt
but it's about half of trump voters it's
not most people in the united states
here is brad raffensberger to his credit
saying that um this is the truth joe
biden got more votes and some people
can't handle it biden did win
and people can't handle the truth
sometimes because they're very
disappointed
in the results i don't get that i voted
for president trump also but the end of
the day
we did everything that we could we did
an audit of the race
president trump still lost then we did a
full recount president trump still lost
then we audited the absentee ballot
signatures
of the envelopes and cobb county and we
found only two votes out of fifteen
thousand that we
went ahead and surveyed along with gbi
only two out of
fifteen thousand that weren't done
correctly and they were actually the
spouses that
filled out those applications for their
spouses or signed the signatures
and so we have a safe secure process and
people have to realize
that you need to get out and vote and
that's how you win elections getting out
and voting
is how you win which brings up a real
question about whether telling georgia
republicans
that the elections there are rigged is a
good way to get out the vote and by the
way
notice that in his answer brad
raffensberger
does basically agree with the premises
of the question from david asman
but he says the numbers just weren't
there raffensberger says
you know yeah it doesn't really make
sense i mean biden was in his basement
trump did great with operation warp
speed i supported trump
uh but we just couldn't find the votes
not enough people
turned out uh so even in his answer
there
um still conceding a bunch of the
framing of the question by david asman
so
there you have it and this is we there's
i mentioned this earlier one-upmanship
battle i
expect that once trump finally leaves
office
we are going to see um oan
and newsmax by virtue of their wild
reporting
push or drag some aspects of fox news to
become even more
radicalized to maintain an audience
that's my expectation
we'll see if it comes true okay we have
a voicemail number
that number is 2192 david p
i really like this voicemail as many of
you know
um and we covered it earlier today
donald trump was caught on an audio
recording of a phone call with the
georgia
secretary of state asking them to find
him
eleven thousand 11 780 votes which would
give him a win in georgia over joe biden
now even if they did that
it wouldn't flip the results of the
election because joe biden won enough
other states to win
anyway but um this caller points out
something
sort of tongue-in-cheek but that we are
hearing who recorded the call
it was illegal to record the call that's
the focus take a listen
hi david so yeah everyone's talking
about this
phone call and i just want to say i
think it was absolutely perfect
there was absolutely it was a perfect
phone call there was nothing wrong with
it
perfect um uh there should be
doing some investigations for illegally
recording it right
yeah illegally recording a perfect phone
call is just yeah
so um i i get that they're joking but
there's a few things here to talk about
number one
both sides you know that i i don't both
sides almost anything
both sides mostly play this game when
there is a leak
and they like the content of the leak
they focus on the content and they
ignore how it was obtained
when they don't like the content of the
leak they say whoa hold on a second
that was illegally recorded or it was
leaked by someone who didn't have access
to it or
whatever democrats and republicans
really both do this
almost to the same degree and it's one
of the areas where there really is very
little difference between democrats and
republicans however
what is interesting is that presumably
donald trump well we know donald trump
was in
washington dc when this call was made
and brad raffensberger was in georgia
when this call was made
both georgia and dc are two par are one
party consent
territories meaning it is legal to refer
to record a phone call
as long as someone on the call knows
that it's being recorded
the question is if the people who were
doing the recording
and knew it was being recorded were in
georgia and
no one in dc knew it i am not a lawyer
as many of you know my question would be
does dc law about one party consent
mean that at least one party in dc
needs to know that it's being recorded
for it to be legal i don't know the
answer to that
and these one party versus two-party
consent things when you have different
laws in different states when the two
states on
a call have different laws this becomes
a federal issue
and anyway it's it's kind of a whole
bigger topic
but it may not actually have been an
illegal recording here it's quite
possible because both
territories are one-party consent uh
that this was actually
perfectly legal to record assuming some
of the parties on the call were the ones
doing the recording
we don't have that information yet i am
sure
that one of the many lawyers in the
audience will
um uh clarify this for me but yes uh
they that
we should be outraged not that trump
is openly pressuring people to steal the
election we should be outraged that this
was recorded
give me a break guys come on we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
hear
about our new year's vacations which
were
for me anyway very boring we will look
back at 2020's covid
insurance lawsuits very interesting
we'll talk about new food waste laws in
china
and donald trump is set to award medals
of freedom
to cuckoo for coco puffs congressman
devin nunes and jim
i also almost said jim shorts jordan jim
jordan
okay why i'll tell you on the bonus show
get
instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at joinedpakman.com
and remember that we are hoping for a
better 2021
and you can use the coupon code better21
to get a big discount off of the
membership of your choice
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman if you're
trying to quit smoking or vaping check
out
lucy which is a nicotine gum developed
by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20 percent
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman